normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government ladies
and gentlemen I got such amazing news
for all of you this is from US News
Maryland handgun licensure law is
unconstitutional US court rules this is
massive okay a US appeals court this is
federal on Tuesday declared that
Maryland's licensing requirements for
people seeking to buy handguns were
unconstitutional setting a land US
Supreme Court decision last year that
expanded gun rights let me break it down
for you in Maryland to get a gun you got
to take a safety class like a 4-Hour
program and like and then get a license
and then you can do this a lot of states
do this and now the US federal court has
just said not anymore this is a major
milestone in Universal federal
constitutional carry which we should
have because the the the uh Constitution
is federal yet state by state we are
still fighting this battle of con
constitutional carry now more than half
the country is constitutional carry and
those that remain the evil States they
call them the evil seven they're now
losing time and time again this will
probably get appealed we'll see what
happens if it goes to the Supreme Court
but for the time being a massive Victory
so at first we had this lawsuit it was
it was bruan I think it was bruan right
where they said you can't uh you have to
issue a permit if a permit is requested
New Jersey and Maryland and New York are
are are three examples of states where
you'd go in and say I'd like to get a
gun they'd say great F out this form and
the form would say what's your reason
and if you were like I'm an American
citizen who wants to keep in bare arms
they'd say not good enough and they'd
deny you your permit or they'd lie so
the Supreme Court says no no no that's
unconstitutional you're you're borring
guns you have to do it Maryland and New
Jersey were and New York would not give
you a permit they'd give you one only if
you were rich or famous and could prove
you are rich and famous the other the
other way to get it is if you uh uh like
if you handle large sums of cash like
working at a bank they would allow you
to get a permit as a security guard but
so almost nobody gets them now they've
lost that and the latest news is they
said okay fine you can get a gun but you
got to take a class and now the courts
are like nah you don't you can have a
gun so Maryland is about to be forced by
judicial review to become constitutional
carry this this rule is a major push we
may eventually see and I'm talking like
in a in two or three years maybe four
depending on how long it takes the
Supreme Court but we could see in the
next several years Nationwide
constitutional carry which means you can
be in Maryland and carry concealed and
drive to any state you want and not go
to prison for doing so yeah which is
insane if you think about it because the
Constitution of the United States says
you have the right to keep in bar arms
so why is that if you go to from
Virginia to West Virginia you're fine
and if you go to Maryland now you're
committing a felony that's insane
because Maryland doesn't think you
should have a gun right and also
Maryland has you know a very intense
crime R city city I'm talking about B of
course uh they don't know how to handle
these issues but they think we'll ban
guns and that will make everything okay
they don't understand the problems they
have because they don't acknowledge what
they're trying to say if you look at
Brazil when BOS Ando came in I don't
agree with everything BOS Ando did but
one of the things he did is he said
people should be able to own firearms
and crime dropped during his period my
wife's Brazilian so my kids are all half
Brazilian we spend time a lot of time
down there but crime dropped by
30% during his time amazing and all the
academics were trying to explain it away
and say well it wasn't because of guns
it was because of the air other good
policies that he was implementing please
name which one he just got lucky he got
it was was he doing what they did in San
Francisco making crime legal and then
not classifying it as a crime
anymore serious question I don't know no
bolaro is kind of the opposite end of
that one he's the lock him up and throw
away the key type 30% do you know how
much of that la la like VI was violent
crime that dimin I I don't know the all
the the super details but it was it was
stunning how much impact it had amazing
oh jeez well I I I uh um I can't
remember which state it was but I
remember a story that I that I learned
about when I was like
18 that um it might have been Michigan
or Wisconsin some State enacted a gun
control law and then crime skyrocketed
like 87% so they immediately uh repealed
it like oh crap that was a big mistake
and uh Illinois just outside of Chicago
has has has the a City with some of the
highest crime in in the country believe
it or not a lot of people think you're
going to get the highest crime rates in
like per City but yes there's this one
part of uh Illinois that has one of the
highest crime rates it's actually a
wealthy shopping district so it's not
murders and stuff it's just everybody's
getting robbed and mugged nonstop look
man if you live in
Illinois these criminals know you don't
got a gun is there a value to make it
constitutionally legal Statewide except
for in the big cities or that just cause
too much confusion and if you ever had
to like go like I think about Tennessee
where there are three major cities
across it if you ever to drive across
Tennessee what are you going to do like
go around it to avoid it at some point
you're just putting a burden on the law
abiding citizens and you're not actually
dealing with those people who don't care
about your laws and will bring a gun
there anyways I guess are the highways
aren't are the highways federal or are
they all state they're Federal well no I
mean they're state and federal highways
so typically the way the law is supposed
to work is if you're on a Federal
Highway an interstate you're allowed to
carry as you know under certain
circumstances
typically you're allowed to transport
but if you get off at any point for gas
oh they're going to get you I know
people who had this happen to them
otherwise if you don't have this what
happens is you end up if you're in s Pao
or any area of Brazil and it hasn't but
guns have been illegal for a long time
there before bus and arrow you have
these walls that are as tall as your
ceiling and on top of the walls it's
just a bunch of broken glass bottles
cemented into the top of the wall
because people are poor they can't
afford really great security and so they
just build a big wall and put broken
glass bottles on they build a wall you
say great idea so this is actually crazy
but around every single little tiny
house there's a wall with broken glass
bottles that's that's your last defense
when you don't have any way to defend
yourself and if you call the police
they'll show up in like an hour oh right
I mean but I mean let's be honest that's
that's how it is in the US yeah it's
starting to get that way I my experience
in Chicago has always been that way okay
I'm I'm a farm boy so subb was so the
only see the only consideration when
you're in the rural areas is how long
will it take for them to drive there
that's right CU they'll come as fast as
they can ex but it might be 20 minutes
but in the city you could have a police
station down the street and this has
happened to me and my family and had
someone you know let's just say engaging
in violence against our property and
literally a block away and the cops
didn't show up for half an hour it's CU
they're dealing with like like actual
violent murder or something or they're
passing out parking tickets yeah or they
just or they're just like who cares like
what are we going to do about it in the
suburbs like man that sounds really bad
we we'll stay away from there it was
okay response some in the suburbs but
out in the country like I mean 20
minutes is not acceptable I don't well
this is the reality man when when when I
lived in Florida if we if we we didn't
have police if we called the sheriff it
was going to be an hour hour and a half
so you need a gun that I was talking to
a friend of mine who was like there is
no she told me there's absolutely no
reason anyone should have a gun give me
one reason I said okay well I lived in
uh rural Florida uh 40 Mi outside of
Miami on a 5 acre property and we didn't
have a gun we had a uh uh a break break
action air uh compression 22 pellet
rifle and uh there was a there was word
going around the neighbors that uh
someone had been murdered it was a home
invasion illegal illegal immigrants had
had broken in and killed some people and
they were not caught so one day me and
my friends are hanging out in the
kitchen we're making pizzas because we'd
like to just make all different kinds of
pizza for fun we make weird ones we made
a fruit pizza once with like jam and
Kiwis and stuff just goofing off and uh
I see a guy in my backyard with a
flashlight and I'm like the there are
6ot tall fences surrounding the property
and so I'm like okay I can call Sheriff
right now and maybe in an hour and a
half we'll figure it out so I'm not
going to say it's a responsible thing to
do but I uh I compressed air in the
rifle went out dry fired bang and I
yelled hey they bolted jumped the fence
and they were gone perhaps the smartest
thing to do it's all I it's all I could
do at the time and it made me think like
we probably shouldn't be out here unless
we're able to defend ourselves
and so I said okay what would have
happened if that was the murderer who
who had you know killed somebody else
and you realized it was just an airsoft
gun or or no no I didn't have anything I
mean they hear a bang they run for it
they're not going to try and figure out
what it was it's a it's it's it's it's a
loud it's a loud weapon and and to be
honest those things are are dangerous
not as dangerous as like a Ruger 1022
but let's say we're totally
disarmed and this guy comes up to the
property armed should I I I call the
police they'll be here in an hour and a
half what should I do you're back to the
biggest man wins she had no answer she
had no answer she's like I don't know
the person shouldn't have a gun I'm like
you're right but they have one cuz
they're committing a crime what should I
do should I just die you should tell
them they shouldn't have a gun and then
they'll be like oh my mistake I'll put
it down and let me pause the game
there's no answer the answer is you need
to be able to defend yourself from bad
people and law abiding citizens are not
the risk yeah yeah just and you guys are
parents like when your kids are old
enough to live by themselves would you
feel better if they like live had a gun
and knew how to how to defend themselves
if they live alone them on what to do it
does make sense it's weird to me
the response to I have a fear about gun
is to ban them as opposed to train more
people to know how to operate them and
to feel comfortable with them and that
means that you're not probably not
addressing what your actual fear is
which is crime and that's a different
conversation than I remember after the
Aurora Colorado shooting I said to my
wife and I was just like I'm never like
I'm getting a gun and I have a phobia of
pistols I like not because I don't I'm a
big supporter of self-defense in the
Second Amendment but have a phobia so
I'm going to go take classes down in
Nevada a week-long class on how to do
this and I'm going to become as well
trained as any police officer so that I
know and I have confidence that I know
how to use it and I know how to protect
myself and I'll never regret being in
like that I didn't do that right
um but I wanted I wanted to be trained I
wanted to know and to try to get rid of
the phobia yeah and according to
self-defense instructors you'll be the
guy that they run to if anything pops
off cuz they all know you know what
you're doing and you'll be they'll be
clinging to you theyy just in from a
super chatter Oregon uh Oregon Oregon
judge struck down a gun control measure
just within the last three hours uh
we're winning too fast here Harney
County Judge rules Oregon gun meas get
tired of winning measure 114
unconstitutional it looked like they
were trying to create a 30-day uh delay
really intense roles but they shut that
down I'm get I'm getting tired of
winning guys we're just winning too much
she's going to have to get used to it
let's talk about what you guys are
working on now because you've got a new
movie coming out on uh not this this
week December 1st yeah the next next
week Friday this is a good one this is a
good one should we should we play the
trailer they're all good though right no
they're all good because they all pass
the guild thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time